This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. As you may have gathered over the years, I'm a deeply rational person. Whenever I see a problem, I try and use logic to solve it. Over the years, I've started to see problems with my approach. Very often, I've discovered that logic is not the best way to get to solutions, especially for problems involving human behavior. We've built a number of podcast episodes around this idea. We've looked, for example, at the Evolution of Religion, at the placebo effect in medicine, and the show we are bringing
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。正如你们这些年可能已经感觉到的那样，我是一个极其理性的人。每当我看到问题时，我都会试图用逻辑来解决它。多年来，我开始发现我的这种方法存在问题。很多时候，我发现逻辑并不是找到解决方案的最佳途径，尤其是对于涉及人类行为的问题。我们围绕这个理念制作了许多播客节目。例如，我们探讨了宗教的演变、医学中的安慰剂效应，以及我们今天带给
you today, a favorite episode from 2019, about the power of brands. All of these conversations prompted me to do more research and thinking. When is rationality useful? And when is it an impediment? Can self-deception ever be a good thing? Can we better address the problems with delusional thinking by understanding the emotional defense mechanisms that trigger such beliefs? These counterintuitive ideas are at the core of a new book I've written.
大家的节目——2019年的一期热门节目，关于品牌的力量。所有这些对话都促使我进行更多的研究和思考。理性在什么时候是有用的？又在什么时候是一种阻碍？自我欺骗有时会是一件好事吗？我们能否通过理解引发此类信念的情感防御机制，更好地解决妄想思维带来的问题？这些反直觉的想法正是我新书的核心所在。
It's called Useful Delusions and it's available now for pre-order. You can learn more at hiddenbrain.org slash books. Okay, here's today's show. Hope you enjoy it. All of us are surrounded by brands. Designer brands. Calvin Klein's obsession. Oh, the smell of it. A brand.
这本书名叫《有用的妄想》（Useful Delusions），现在已经可以预订了。你可以在 hiddenbrain.org/books 了解更多信息。好的，这就是今天的节目。希望你们喜欢。我们所有人都被各种品牌包围着。设计师品牌。卡尔文·克莱因的“迷恋”（Obsession）。哦，那个气味。一个品牌。
Bargain shopper brands. You can spend $20 every month on paper towels anyway. designer brands, Kelvin Klein's obsession, the smell of it, a print, Bargain Shopper brands, you're gonna spend $20 every month on paper towels anyway, you're throwing your money away, the mini-share wows are for everything, for every day, brands were seemingly every demographic slice among us. Good morning, I'm Wilfred Brimley
精打细算型消费者的品牌。反正你每个月都要花20美元买纸巾。设计师品牌，卡尔文·克莱因的“迷恋”，那个气味，一个印记。精打细算型消费者的品牌，反正你每个月都要花20美元买纸巾，你是在浪费钱，迷你版“秀活力”（Bounty）纸巾适用于一切，适用于每一天。品牌似乎存在于我们当中的每一个人口统计群体中。早上好，我是威尔弗雷德·布里姆利，
and I'd like to talk to you for a few minutes about diabetes. Actually about diabetes. Have you ever stopped to ask, how brands influence you? Is it the slick advertising, the relatable characters, or the story? Lance Armstrong will go out there with the story of I Beat Cancer. And I'm going to put on my gear, I'm going to put on that yellow bracelet. I had about 50 of them.
我想和大家聊几分钟关于糖尿病的事。实际上是关于糖尿病的。你有没有停下来问过自己，品牌是如何影响你的？是华丽的广告、有共鸣的角色，还是背后的故事？兰斯·阿姆斯特朗会带着“我战胜了癌症”的故事走出去。我要穿上我的装备，我要戴上那条黄色的手环。我大约有50条这样的手环。
This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of brands and how we relate to them. How companies create a world view around the products they sell and then get us to make those products a part of who we are. America's Read knows what it feels like to be an outsider, to be surrounded by strangers and to have to figure out how to fit in. Today, he's a professor of marketing at the University of Pennsylvania. But when he was 17, he was the new kid, one of a handful of black students bused to a predominantly white school. He remembers his first day, getting on the bus with the other black kids from far away
本周的《隐藏大脑》，我们将探讨品牌的心理学以及我们与它们的关系。公司如何围绕他们销售的产品创造一种世界观，然后让我们将这些产品变成我们自身的一部分。阿米拉斯·里德深知作为局外人的感觉，被陌生人包围，不得不弄清楚如何融入其中。如今，他是宾夕法尼亚大学的市场营销学教授。但当他17岁时，他是那个新来的孩子，是一小群被用校车送到以白人为主的学校的黑人学生之一。他记得第一天，和来自遥远社区的其他黑人孩子一起上车。
neighborhoods. They were scared, but we didn't want to show any weakness so we kind of walled stand and walked in with confidence, and I remember the world stopping and everyone looking up and sort of saying, who are those guys? He wanted to be accepted. So he came up with a plan. He would become a social chameleon. I sort of settled on this idea that I would try to be what was almost like a boundary
他们很害怕，但我们不想表现出任何软弱，所以我们有点像筑起心墙，自信地走了进去，我记得世界仿佛停转了，所有人都抬起头，仿佛在说：“那些家伙是谁？”他渴望被接纳。于是他想出了一个计划。他要成为一个社交变色龙。我大致确定了这样一个想法：我会努力做一个类似于边界跨越者的人。
spanner. So I hung out with the nerds, I hung out with the jocks, I hung out with the musicians, I hung out with all different groups. And in that sort of social chameleon as I would sort of go from group to group, I would try to kind of fit in in a way that allowed me to have some kind of affiliation with that group. As he spent time with these different clicks, he noticed that each had its own set of badges, its own language.
所以我跟书呆子混在一起，跟运动员混在一起，跟音乐人混在一起，我跟所有不同的群体都混在一起。作为那种社交变色龙，当我从一个群体转到另一个群体时，我会努力融入其中，以便与那个群体建立某种程度的归属感。当他在这些不同的圈子里花时间时，他注意到每个圈子都有自己的一套标志、自己的语言。
And he realized that if he could speak that language, adopt those badges, he would start to blend in. So he started buying stuff. He started wearing the things the other kids wore. Often it was about shoes. With the athletes, he wore Nike's, with the musicians, Chuck Taylor's. With the hip-hop kids, Adidas, but without the shoelaces, they were like costumes, only deeper.
他意识到，如果他能说那种语言，采用那些标志，他就会开始融入其中。于是他开始买东西。他开始穿其他孩子穿的衣服。通常这关乎鞋子。跟运动员在一起时，他穿耐克；跟音乐人在一起时，他穿匡威（Chuck Taylor）；跟嘻哈少年在一起时，他穿阿迪达斯，但不系鞋带。它们就像是服装，但又不仅于此。
A brand can communicate something. How you wear your pants can communicate something. The particular sort of portfolio of colors that you choose to adorn yourself with can communicate something. America's understood that personal brands are like flags. They tell the world who you are or who you want to be. They telegraph, I'm the smart kid, I'm the rich kid,
一个品牌可以传达某些东西。你如何穿裤子可以传达某些东西。你选择用来装饰自己的特定颜色组合可以传达某些东西。阿米拉斯明白，个人品牌就像旗帜。它们向世界表明你是谁，或者你想成为谁。它们发送电报般的信号：我是聪明的小孩，我是富有的小孩，
I'm the athlete. They're a form of self-expression. A brand is so much more than a tagline or logo. It is more of a meaning system. And so a brand is kind of a promise to deliver on those values and to connect consumers who might have, in their minds, a sense of synchronicity with what they believe those values are.
我是运动员。它们是一种自我表达的形式。一个品牌远不止是一个标语或徽标。它更是一个意义系统。因此，品牌是一种承诺，要兑现这些价值，并将那些在心目中对其所相信的价值观有同步感的消费者连接起来。
We'll talk more in the second half of our conversation about the psychology of brands and the link between brands and behavior, but I want to start by looking at some examples of what you're talking about, America's. There are people who say, look brands don't matter, as you said, I just buy what's functional. And then there are people like these characters from the CBC TV show Kim's convenience. What are you doing? Oh, these shoes don't play basketball. They're basketball shoes.
在对话的后半部分，我们将更多地讨论品牌心理学以及品牌与行为之间的联系，但我想先看一些你所讨论的内容的例子，阿米拉斯。有些人会说，看吧，品牌不重要，正如你所说，我只买实用主义的东西。然后还有一些人，比如CBC电视剧《金氏便利店》里的这些角色。你在干什么？哦，这些鞋不能打篮球。它们是篮球鞋。
You can tell by the little man playing basketball on them. No, your shoes are basketball shoes. My shoes are collector's items. And I intend to keep them that way. Ah, it gets to be bad if you got some breeders that have them sneaks, huh? Get that breed away from me. Get your shoes away from my special edition breed of.
看鞋上的小人在打篮球就知道了。不，你的鞋是篮球鞋。我的鞋是收藏品。我打算让它们一直保持那样。啊，你要是有些拿这种运动鞋当宝贝的人，那就糟了，哈？离我的宝贝远点。把你的鞋从我的特别版宝贝旁边拿开。
Dude, I'm not joking. These shoes, they're my legacy. Bleh. So talk to me, America's about what's going on here. How can a pair of shoes feel like a legacy? I think that it's very interesting, Shankar, because a pair of shoes, if positioned the right way, can encapsulate a story.
老兄，我不是在开玩笑。这些鞋，它们是我的传家宝。呸。那么阿米拉斯，跟我聊聊这里发生了什么。一双鞋怎么能感觉像是一代传家宝？我觉得这非常有趣，尚卡尔，因为一双鞋，如果定位得当，可以封装一个故事。
And that story might be, for example, position the right way can encapsulate a story. And that story might be, for example, a story about success, or a story about overcoming the odds, or a story about being able to have a kind of level of greatness that you would not be able to have but for the shoes. And so when Michael Jordan puts his shoes out there, there is the idea that it is very clear, right? So it says, be like Mike. What does that mean? It literally means that if I wear
而这个故事可能是，例如，定位得当可以封装一个故事。而这个故事可能是，例如，一个关于成功的故事，一个关于战胜困难的故事，或者是一个关于能够拥有某种程度的伟大（而如果没有这双鞋你就无法拥有）的故事。因此，当迈克尔·乔丹推出他的鞋子时，其中的理念非常明确，对吧？所以它说：像迈克一样。那是什么意思？字面意思就是，如果我穿
these shoes, I will sort of encapsulate some of that mystique because I am wearing the shoes as well. And so it's a very powerful way that a brand can tell a story that can connect with a person's or a consumer's sense of identity that can then create this sense of legacy that the individual in the clip was referring to. So when you think about brands in the way that you're describing them, not as tags or even as just as names or commercial, a way to sort of commercially identify a product, but really as stories, as narratives, how valuable are these stories commercially speaking? Oh, they're tremendously valuable.
着这双鞋，我将某种程度上封装那种神秘感，因为我也穿着这双鞋。因此，这是品牌讲述故事的一种非常有力的方式，能够与个人或消费者的认同感产生联系，从而创造出片中个人所提及的那种传家宝的感觉。所以，当你以你所描述的方式思考品牌时——不是将其视为标签、名称或商业标识（一种在商业上识别产品的方法），而是真正将其视为故事、叙事——从商业角度来看，这些故事有多大价值？哦，它们的价值巨大。
And the reason that they're valuable is because they create a kind of impervious connection that's hard to break. If a consumer connects with a brand or a product in terms of an identity argument, instead of an argument about how better the features are of the product compared to something else they could buy. Then what is happening is that there is an installation
它们之所以有价值，是因为它们创造了一种难以打破的坚不可摧的联系。如果消费者从认同感的角度（而不是从产品的功能比他们能买的其他东西好多少的角度）与某个品牌或产品建立联系。那么发生的情况就是，
from the brand's competitive attacks because once a person believes that a brand is part of who they are, then asking them to go to another brand is essentially asking them to change who they are. And that is an incredibly powerful, psychological, gravitational pull that is really hard to overcome. And that value in terms of customer lifetime value
该品牌得到了对竞争攻击的免疫保护，因为一旦一个人相信某个品牌是他们自身的一部分，那么要求他们转向另一个品牌，本质上就是要求他们改变自己。这是一股极其强大的心理引力，真的很难克服。从客户终身价值的角度来看，这种价值
is a real like economic entity, because it literally means that the person is gonna be on board and be buying for a very long time and be willing to do your own marketing, basically for free, because they are advocates of the brand. They are what we refer to as brand evangelists, because they are now willing to go out there and protect the brand. So that value is massive in terms of creating this type of connection that can last with consumers for a very long time.
是一个真实的经济实体，因为这字面意思意味着这个人会一直坚定支持并长期购买，并且愿意基本上免费为你做自己的营销，因为他们是该品牌的拥护者。他们就是我们所说的品牌传道者，因为他们现在愿意走出去保护这个品牌。因此，在与消费者建立这种能够持续很长时间的联系方面，这种价值是巨大的。
You've used a technique called social listening to study the fans of a very iconic brand, the tech company Apple. What is this technique and what do you observe among Apple fans? This technique called social listening is a combination of artificial intelligence and machine learning, where we literally go out into the internet and we identify conversations that people are having online about brands.
你曾使用一种叫做“社交聆听”的技术来研究一个极具标志性的品牌——科技公司苹果的粉丝。这项技术是什么？你在苹果粉丝身上观察到了什么？这项被称为社交聆听的技术是人工智能和机器学习的结合，我们字面意义上进入互联网，识别人们在网上针对品牌展开的对话。
And what we particularly find with Apple is that there is a special unique kind of conversation quality that happens between very fiercely loyal Apple users. And they talk about the brand in a fascinating way. There is language about the brand that almost feels as if the individual consumer is talking about religion or politics. There's a kind of fierce, very powerful emotional way that consumers talk about the Apple brand. So today I'm gonna be showing you all of the Apple products
我们在苹果身上特别发现的是，在极其忠诚的苹果用户之间存在一种特殊且独特的对话品质。他们以一种迷人的方式谈论这个品牌。关于品牌的语言几乎让人觉得个人消费者是在谈论宗教或政治。消费者谈论苹果品牌时，有一种激烈且极具情感的方式。所以今天我要向大家展示我拥有的
that I own from old to new Everything that I own from Apple Something else, word shirt mode. Oh my god. I'm literally obsessed with Portion mode Just because I mentioned that I have an apple tattoo in my arm and I wouldn't say I Would get it again. I was 100% Apple obsessed like I would say 75% of the conversations that I had Ended up talking about Apple in some way And so Apple has been very good at creating this kind of emotional connection such that consumers once they are on board Apple can basically say, hey, we
所有苹果产品，从旧到新。我拥有的所有苹果产品……还有别的东西，单词衬衫模式。哦，天哪。我简直对“部分模式”（portion mode）着迷了，就因为我提到我在手臂上有个苹果纹身，我不会说我会再去纹一个。我当时100%沉迷于苹果，我可以说我进行的对话中大约75%最终都以某种方式谈论了苹果。因此，苹果非常擅长创造这种情感连接，以至于消费者一旦加入苹果，苹果基本上可以说：嘿，我们
would like for you to buy a new charger, which is kind of absurd. But consumers are like, sure, I'll do that because they are so bought in, whereas they could go to Android and they could not have to ever deal with buying new chargers, et cetera, et cetera. But they're willing to do it. They're willing to stand outside in the cold, shunker, in a line, and wait for hours and hours and commiserate with fellow Apple Loyalists
希望你买一个新的充电器。这有点荒谬。但消费者会说：没问题，我买。因为他们深信不疑，而他们本可以去买安卓（Android），从而永远不必应付购买新充电器之类的事情。但他们甘愿这样做。尚卡尔，他们甚至愿意大冷天地站在外面排队，等上几个小时，与同为苹果忠实拥趸的人们诉苦，
to get that shiny new thing in the box. They don't have to do that. There's something that is not rational about this. And it's reflected when we look at and analyze the text conversations that occur between these fiercely loyal Apple folks. Now Apple fans might say they are not deluded about their gizmos. They might argue that Apple products are objectively better than other tech products. But America's point's out that you see the same brand loyalty
只为了拿到盒子里那个亮闪闪的新玩意儿。他们本不必这么做。这里面有些东西是不理性的。当我们观察和分析这些极其忠诚的苹果粉丝之间发生的文字对话时，这一点得到了反映。现在，苹果粉丝可能会说，他们对自己的小玩意儿并没有产生妄想。他们可能会辩称，苹果产品客观上比其他科技产品更好。但阿米拉斯指出，
when two products are objectively identical. The example that I always use in my class is a very simple example of over-the-counter pharmaceuticals, the Walmart or the Walgreens brand versus Tylenol, and the fact that you can have a product that is essentially identical in terms of its active ingredients, versus Tylenol and the fact that you can have a product that is essentially identical in terms of its active ingredients, but yet one will cost 27% more in the store. And people know that the Walgreens brand is the same thing as the Tylenol brand.
当两个产品客观上完全相同时，你也会看到同样的品牌忠诚度。我在课堂上经常举的一个非常简单的例子是非处方药，沃尔玛或沃尔格林（Walgreens）的自有品牌与泰诺（Tylenol）相比，你可以买到一个在活性成分上本质上完全相同的产品，但与泰诺相比，其中一个在店里的售价要高出27%。人们明明知道沃尔格林品牌的东西和泰诺品牌是一样的。
And that entire market for Tylenol actually shouldn't exist if people are rational. But what it says is there's something else above and beyond the features that has utility. You can also see the power of brand loyalty in sports. America has spent a lot of time analyzing fans of the Philadelphia Eagles football team. People like Patrick Muller, who demonstrates his commitment to the Eagles with a massive RV plastered with the team mascot and logo. Eagle 1 is Patrick Muller's $300,000 homage to his beloved Philadelphia Eagles.
如果人们是理性的，那么泰诺的整个市场其实本不应该存在。但这就说明，除了产品功能之外，还有其他东西具有实用价值。你也可以在体育运动中看到品牌忠诚度的力量。阿米拉斯花了很多时间分析费城老鹰橄榄球队的粉丝。比如帕特里克·穆勒（Patrick Muller）这样的人，他用一辆印有球队吉祥物和徽标的巨型房车来表达他对老鹰队的忠诚。“老鹰1号”是帕特里克·穆勒为他深爱的费城老鹰队花费30万美元打造的致敬之作。
I'm sure there's not any Eagle fan who has been more to games than I have in the last six years. Since 2006, this eagle has nested it every single game, home and away. Talk about this, America. How do people like Mueller go from being consumers of a product to effectively being ambassadors of the product? The eagles are intricately connected with the city of Philadelphia, right? The scrappy, gritty city of Philadelphia, the underdog Philadelphia, the blue collar Philadelphia and for Patrick, you know, living those values
我敢说，在过去六年里，没有哪个老鹰队球迷去看比赛的次数比我更多。自2006年以来，这只“老鹰”出现在每一场比赛中，无论是主场还是客场。谈谈这个吧，阿米拉斯。像穆勒这样的人是如何从一个产品的消费者转变为该产品的形象大使的？老鹰队与费城这座城市紧密相连，对吧？那个百折不挠、坚韧不拔的费城，那个处于劣势的费城，那个蓝领阶层的费城。对帕特里克来说，你知道，践行这些价值观，
and going to those games and being there when the team is awful and wanting to like represent your city through the sport, through the Eagles. It's something that's a special kind of characteristic, especially in this city, of those fans that are Philly sports fans and so for Patrick, he essentially immersed himself into this identity and almost lost himself.
去观看那些比赛，在球队表现糟糕时依然陪伴左右，并想要通过这项运动、通过老鹰队来代表你的城市。这是一种特殊的特质，尤其是在这座城市，那些费城体育迷身上。所以对帕特里克来说，他本质上让自己沉浸在这个身份中，几乎迷失了自我。
His identity, I would say, Shunker is completely fused with being an Eagles fan. He's literally taken this beautiful RV and he's gone to all of the games since 2006. I mean, think about, we gotta have a lot of time in your hands, but think about the commitment. Think about the loyalty to do this and to create an image and a spectacle
尚卡尔，可以说他的身份已经完全与老鹰队球迷的身份融合在一起了。他字面意义上开着这辆漂亮的房车，去参加了2006年以来的每一场比赛。我的意思是，想想看，你得有大量的闲暇时间，但想想这种承诺。想想这种忠诚度，为了做到这一点，去创造一个形象、一场奇观，
and the Philadelphia Eagles. If you're a brand, you're like, oh my God, how do I clone Mullers of the world, right? How do I get all these fans to get so excited that they'll put the tattoo on their body? They'll, how do I get people to do that to be my sort of walking billboard, my one man, one woman marketing department for free?
支持费城老鹰队。如果你是一个品牌，你一定会想：天哪，我该如何克隆出世上的“穆勒”们，对吧？我该如何让所有这些球迷如此兴奋，以至于他们愿意把纹身文在身上？我该怎么让人这样做，来免费充当我的移动广告牌、我的单人营销部门？
And this is beautiful because it points to the fact that if you can kind of do what the Eagles did with respect to keeping consistent and authentic with their story, you can create these types of fans, draw them in and reinforce what they want to try to express to others. And so, promoting him and sort of bringing him to the forefront for the Eagles franchise
这太美妙了，因为它指出了这样一个事实：如果你能做到老鹰队所做的事——在他们的故事中保持一致性和真实性，你就能创造出这类粉丝，吸引他们进来，并强化他们想要向他人表达的东西。因此，为老鹰队特许经营权和橄榄球队推广他并把他推向最前沿，是一件天才之举，因为你实际上只是在利用这样一个事实：你拥有一个狂热的布道者，他如此深度地融入了你的品牌，以至于他愿意做这些事情来代表你发声。因此，如果有些公司实际上想要从零开始打造这些品牌，从头建立它们，许多公司现在当然认识到这是一件很有力量的事情，所以许多公司现在当然认识到，这是一件很有力量的事情。
and football team is a genius thing to do because you're literally just piggybacking on the fact that you've got a hard core evangelist that is so wrapped up in your brand that he's willing to do these things to advocate on your behalf. So if you have companies that actually want to create these brands from scratch to build them up from the ground, lots of companies now recognize of course that this is a powerful thing to do, so lots of companies now recognize, of course, that this is a powerful thing to do.
因此，许多公司都想分一杯羹。这是埃伦·德杰尼勒斯（Ellen DeGeneres）关于一家公司打造独特品牌之努力的一段剪辑。这是来自笔业公司比克（BIC）的一个新产品。他们有一个新的笔系列，叫做“女士比克”（BIC for her）。这绝对是真的。这是专为女士设计的笔。我知道你在想什么。
So lots of companies want in on this. Here's a clip from Ellen DeGeneres about one company's efforts to create a distinctive brand. It's a new product from BIC, the Penn Company. And they have a new line of pens called BIC for her. And this is totally real. They're pens just for ladies. I know what you're thinking.
真是千呼万唤始出来啊。我们的笔去哪儿了，伙计？你敢相信吗？这些年我们一直都在用男士笔。太棒了！那么这里出了什么问题，阿米拉斯？为什么这个广告活动相比于苹果所做的事情显得反响平平？答案是，当一家公司试图聚焦于一个特定身份，去建立
It's about damn time. Where have our pens, man? Can you believe this? We've been using man pens all these years. Yes! So what went wrong here, America? Why did this ad campaign fall flat compared to the stuff that Apple does? The answer is when a company is trying to hone in on a specific identity, to make a
一个联系、一个与其品牌相关的有意义的联系时，它必须以一种几乎是社会学的方式去理解那个身份。而在“女士比克”的案例中，我认为很明显，性别与购买圆珠笔之间的相关性为零。因此，如果你试图讲这样一个故事：这些是专为女性设计的笔，那么如果你没有立刻被踢出大楼，人们就会质问：
connection, a relevant connection to its brand, it has to understand that identity in an almost sociological way. And in the case of Bick for her, I think it's quite clear that the correlation between gender and buying pins is zero. And so if you try to tell a story that says, these are the pins for women, then if you don't get immediately thrown out of the building, the question will be,
好吧，告诉我为什么是这些，为什么？为什么这些笔被称为“专为女性”？而且我认为在“女士比克”这个特定案例中，可以说根本没有内在实质，尚卡尔。它只是被当成了一种噱头。顺便说一句，尚卡尔，在营销和商业界，当人们不知道如何向女性营销时，我们称之为“缩小尺寸并染成粉红色”（shrink it and pink it）。这是一个巨大的错误，因为你根本懒得去试图理解女性。这一点
okay, tell me why these, why? Why are these pins, quote, for women? And I think in the specific case of Big for her, there was nothing underneath the hood, so to speak, Shankar. It was just kind of like perceived as this gimmick. We call this, by the way, Shanker, in the marketing and business world, when you do not know how to market to women, we call it shrink it and pink it. And it's like, it's a huge mistake because you didn't bother to try to understand women. That's
非常清楚。事实上，你走向了相反的方向，讲了一个对女性来说几乎具有侮辱性的故事，这在身份认同方面让女权运动倒退了，因为这就好比：等等，我们不需要属于女性的专用笔。正因为你不理解那个身份，而且你没有认真对待它、没有研究它、没有从社会学角度去解构和分析它、没有试图理解它与特定决策过程的联系，你才会犯下比克所犯的那种愚蠢错误。我想花一点时间谈谈一个非商业、非消费的场景。
very clear. And in fact, you went the opposite way in telling a story that would almost be perceived as insulting to women, like taking the feminist movement backwards in terms of identity because it's like, well, wait a minute, we don't need our, the pen for women. And so because you didn't understand that identity and you didn't, you didn't take it seriously, you didn't study it, you didn't sociologically unpack it and analyze it and try to understand its connection to that specific decision-making process. You make dumb mistakes like how big made. I want to talk a moment about a non-business, non-consumer setting.
共和党人和民主党人并没有将他们的政党视为品牌，但听起来他们与政党的关系几乎就像人们与品牌的关系一样。我想知道，我们在国内看到的共和党人和民主党人之间的敌意，究竟较少与意识形态有关，而更多地与品牌忠诚度有关？政党确实就是品牌。而我们今天、此时此刻正在目睹的，正是当身份、身份忠诚和身份连接彻底失控时那种近乎反常的极端表现。
Republicans and Democrats don't think about their political parties as brands, but it sounds like they almost relate to them in the way people relate to brands. And I'm wondering is the animosity we see in the country between Republicans and Democrats less to do with ideology and more about brand loyalty? Political parties are indeed brands. And what we're witnessing today, right now, is the almost perverse extreme aspect of when identity and identity loyalty and identity connection goes way off the rails.
因此，政党正在变成部落这种观念非常非常清晰，并且正在与他们的身份建立联系，对吧？所以，如果你提出这样一个主张：我想修建一堵墙来协助移民管理，你可以对墙的功能性进行论证，或者你可以像共和党人那样做，进行身份论证，
And so the notion that political parties are now becoming tribes is very, very clear and making connections to their identity, right? So if you have a proposition to say, I would like to build a wall to help with immigration, you can make a functional argument about a wall or you can do what Republicans did, which is to make an identity argument
声称那堵墙代表着将某个群体拒之门外，而由于种种不同的原因，我们不希望他们来到这个国家。这是一个身份论证，这是一个内群体与外-群体的论证，这是一个情感论证，诸如此类。而在另一边，另一边则表示，这堵墙现在代表着与他们自我认知截然相反的东西。它代表着压迫、歧视，它代表着一切邪恶的事物。
to say that wall represents keeping some group of individuals out that we don't want in this country for lots of different reasons. That's an identity argument, that's an in-group out-group argument, that's an emotional argument, and so on. On the other side, the other side says this wall now represents something that is antithetical to how they see themselves. It represents oppression, discrimination, it represents all things evil.
所以双方根本无法坐下来对话，去试图解决如何推进围绕这堵墙的政策的问题，因为这堵墙现在已经成了身份的象征。这一切都关乎你的部落。这一切都关乎你试图保护的价值观，那些你认为自己正试图保护的、被封装在你特定的政治品牌中的价值观。
So there's no way to too can have a conversation about trying to settle an issue on how to move forward with a policy around that wall because the wall now has become a symbol of identity. It's all about your tribe. It's all about the values that you are trying to protect, that you believe that you are trying to protect as they are encapsulated in your particular political brand.
休息之后，当您喜爱的品牌伤了您的心，会发生什么？您正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当阿米拉斯·里德刚过40岁时，医生告诉他膝盖状况很糟糕。他必须放弃篮球和跑步。于是他开始寻找另一项对关节更温和的运动。我开始接触自行车，发现了这项运动，并且立刻爱上了它的文化。就像许多人一样，我与兰斯·阿姆斯特朗品牌产生了共鸣。事实上，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗加上耐克再加上阿米拉斯，等于
When we come back, what happens when your favorite brand breaks your heart? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When America's Reed was in his early 40s, a doctor told him that his knees were in bad shape. He needed to give a basket ball and running. So he started to look for another sport that would be easier on his joints. I got into cycling and found the sport and fell in love with the culture immediately. And like a lot of people, I connected with the Lance Armstrong brand. And actually Lance Armstrong plus Nike plus America's equaled, something that was so
在我心中极具激励意义的东西。兰斯通过实际观看比赛、观看环法自行车赛，将我带入了职业自行车的世界。兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的表现——现在是我在重现——当他冲向终点线时。我爱上了兰斯，因为他的故事，尚卡尔，他战胜癌症的故事，以及“我要穿上我的装备，我要戴上那条黄色的手环”（我大约有50条这样的手环），
aspirational in my mind. Lance brought me into the world of professional cycling in terms of actually watching it, watching the Tour de France. The performance by Lance Armstrong, this is me now, as he drives up to the line. And I fell in love with Lance because his story, Shankar, his story of I beat cancer, and I'm going to put on my gear, I'm going to put on that yellow bracelet, I had about 50 of them,
还有球衣、鞋套、一切。我买了他用过的自行车。我会在外面骑车，我会在内心模仿兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。我会在爬山时想起兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。对我来说，这具有深厚的情感意义。当流言蜚语传出，说什么？等等，人们在指责兰斯·阿姆斯特朗作弊。我是第一个跳出来说：你们错了。
and the jersey, the shoe warm-ups, everything. And I was, I bought the bike that he used. And I would be out there, and I would be channeling Lance Armstrong. I would think about Lance Armstrong in the mountains. And it was for me deeply emotional. And when Little Whisperings came out that, well, wait a minute, people are accusing Lance Armstrong of cheating. I was the first to say, you're wrong.
绝无可能，这没有发生。刚刚宣布的消息，将终身禁赛阿姆斯特朗，并剥夺他的七个环法冠军头衔。从我身份认同的角度来看，这令人心碎，因为发生的事情是我失去了自己的一部分。当真相大白，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是一个骗子，
No way this is not happening. Has just announced moments ago, it will ban Armstrong for life and strip him of his seven tour title. And it was heartbreaking from the perspective of my identity because what happened was I lost a part of myself. And when it came out that Lance Armstrong is a fraud,
兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是一个江湖骗子时，我简直记得我把所有的“坚强直播”（Livestrong）和兰斯·阿姆斯特朗装备收进一个袋子里并把它放在门外的那个日子。尚卡尔，这几乎就像是一场葬礼。这就好像是一个哀悼的时刻，因为这个标志性的、激励人心的自我最终被证明是一个肤浅且空洞的骗局。我感到自己像个傻瓜。在这段与该品牌的关系中，我觉得自己像个傻瓜，因为我一直在试图强化和表达所有这些最终被证明并非事实的价值观。这不是很耐人寻味吗？因为从某种层面上讲，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗表现好不好、他战胜癌症、他赢得环法，其实跟你没有任何关系；而他作弊和服用兴奋剂也跟你没有任何关系。然而，
Lance Armstrong is a charlatan. I literally remember the day that I went and got all of my live strong and Lance Armstrong gear and I put it in a bag and I set it outside. It was almost like a funeral, Shankar. It was like, it was a moment of grieving because this iconic aspirational self turned out to be a shallow and hollow fraud. And I felt foolish. I felt like I was a fool in that relationship with his brand because I was trying to reinforce and express all of these values that turned out not to be true. It's so interesting isn't it? Because at one level, lands are Armstrong doing well, him beating cancer, him winning the Chauda France, really has nothing to do with you and his cheating and his doping also has nothing to do with you. And yet you, you know, triumph to when
当他获胜时你欢呼雀跃，当他跌入谷底时你黯然神伤。你触及了我认为是消费者与品牌之间身份连接的核心前提，尚卡尔。那个理念就是，一旦我的身份与此融合，我就与他的高潮和低谷同步了。虽然他的表现、他的方法与我毫无关系，但我一直在运用那个故事，
he triumphed and you grieved when he fell. That's, you're touching on something I think is the key premise of identity connections between consumers and brands, Shunker. And that's the idea is that once my identity fused with that, I was in sync with his highs and lows. And the idea that even though his performance, his approach had nothing to do with me, I was using that story,
不仅在字面意义上的自行车骑行中，也在我生活中的象征意义上使用它——在某种意义上，当我在职业生涯或个人生活中面临挑战时，我会在脑海中想象并代表骑在自行车上的兰斯。我汲取了那种能量，那种来自品牌、从品牌光环中散发出来、我从品牌中消费的动力之源。
not only on the bike in a literal sense, but also kind of in my life, in a figurative sense, in the sense that I would almost think about mentally represent Lance on the bike when I was faced with a challenge in my professional life or in my personal life. And I used that energy, that motivational impetus
我将其用作推动自己前进、坚持到底的能量源泉，所有那些与在自行车上努力付出、勤奋、信念、相信自己、努力工作、克服巨大障碍等理念相关的价值观联系在一起。
that's coming from the brand, that's haloing off the brand, that I'm consuming from the brand. I'm using that for me as a source of energy that allows me to push through, to soldier on, and all of those different values that are associated with, you know, the idea that I'm putting in the work on the bike, I'm diligent, I believe, I believe in myself, I'm going to work hard and I'm going to overcome great obstacles.
所以，尽管这与我毫无关系，但我一直在汲取那种能量。而当我发现这种能量其实是有毒的时，它最终导致了我内心深处强烈的失落感。你与阿米特·巴塔查吉（Amit Bhattacharjee）和乔纳森·伯曼（Jonathan Burman）进行了一项研究，关于我们有时如何将品牌中存在问题的一面与我们欣赏的方面进行脱钩。如果兰斯·阿姆斯特朗被抓到的是偷窃而不是服用兴奋剂，我在想，你是否能够将你对运动员兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的欣赏与你的厌恶进行脱钩？是否是因为不道德的行为与他的成就在同一领域，才使得它们难以被分离开来？在你引用的那篇论文中，我们将你所讨论的这种概念称为“道德脱钩”，它基于一个基本前提：如果你对某个人有一种天然的倾斜去支持他，那么我们对心理学的了解是，人类
And so, even though it had nothing to do with me, I was drawing upon that energy. And when I found out that the energy was actually poisoned, then it sort of resulted in this deep sense of loss for me. You conducted a study with Amit Bhattacharji and and Jonathan Burman how we sometimes decouple problematic aspects of a brand with the things that we admire about the brand. If Landsaham strong had been caught stealing rather than doping, I'm wondering if you could have decoupled your admiration for Landsaham strong the athlete with your distaste. Was the fact that the unethical behavior was in the same domain as Is accomplishment that made them difficult to disentangle? In the paper that you referenced there we refer to this notion that you're talking about as Moral decoupling and so it's based on the fundamental premise that if there is an individual that you have a natural inclination to want to support, then what we know about psychology is that humans
会想方设法为他们想要支持的那个人合理化支持行为，以维护他们想要拥有的信念。因此，他们会试图以允许他们维护这些信念的方式来诠释他们周围的世界。举个例子，让我们以泰虎·伍兹（Tiger Woods）为例。如果你看看他的故事，他做了什么？好吧，他背叛了妻子。所以，背叛妻子大概与他的高尔夫球技毫无关系。因此，如果你渴望支持泰虎·伍兹，
will figure out ways to rationalize the support for that individual that they want to support to uphold a belief that they want to have. And so they will try to interpret the world around them in ways that allow them to uphold those beliefs. So for example, let's take the example of Tiger Woods. If you look at his story, what did he do? Well, he cheated on his wife. And so, cheating on your wife presumably has nothing to do with your golf game. So, if you desired to support Tiger Woods,
你可以在脑海中进行一种心理辩论，从而反映出道德脱钩。你可能会说：“嗯，你知道，对于他在私生活里可能做过的整件事情，我其实并不赞同。不过，我真的很喜欢他的高尔夫球技。所以我将继续支持他。”关于道德脱钩，有趣的地方在于，如果名人或这个人所做的坏事与你所欣赏的表现无关，
you could make the mental argument in your mind that would reflect moral decoupling. You could say, well, you know, I don't really agree with this whole thing that he might have been doing in his personal life. However, I really like his golf game. So I'm going to continue to support him. And so what's interesting about moral decoupling, if that bad thing that the celebrity or the person does is not related to the performance that you admire,
那么你就可以在脑海中将其拆解开来，你几乎可以忽略（如果你愿意的话）甚至不去评论那件坏事的道德问题，因为你可以简单地专注于他的表现以及你在那个表现领域中对他所做事情的欣赏。这是一个非常有趣的方面，因为在兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的案例中，对我来说这是不可能的。我要跟你说实话，苍天可鉴，我试过。但对我来说，要将兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的这两件事分离开来是不可能的。
then you can pull it apart in your mind and you can almost ignore, if you will, or not even comment on the morality of the bad thing because you can simply focus on the performance and the fact that you admire what they do in that performance domain. And so it's a very interesting aspect because in the case of Lance Armstrong, it was impossible for me. And I'm going to tell you the truth. Lord knows I try. But it was impossible for me to pull those two things apart for Lance Armstrong.
这就是为什么他所有的衣服最后都堆在了我家人行道上的原因。好啦。现在，阿米拉斯，有很多人认为打造品牌的想法简直令人反感。这不过是营销人员和大型公司在哄骗顾客、哄骗消费者。弗兰克·日耳曼（Frank German）、埃伦·加维（Aaron Garvey）和丽莎·博尔顿（Lisa Bolton）
And that's why all of his clothes ended up on my sidewalk. So. Now, there are lots of people, America's who think that the idea of building a brand is just distasteful. It's just marketers and big companies trying to hoodwink customers, hoodwink consumers. Frank, German, Aaron Garvey, and Lisa Bolton
曾经进行过一项有趣的涉及耐克推杆的研究。当我和弗兰克·日耳曼交谈时，他是这样向我解释这项研究的：大约一半的参与者被告知他们将使用耐克推杆进行推击，而另一半参与者则没有被告知他们将使用什么品牌的推杆。重要的是，所有参与者使用的推杆完全相同。而另一半参与者则没有被告知他们将使用什么品牌的推杆。
once conducted an interesting study involving Nike putters. And when I spoke with Frank German, here's how he explained the study to me. About half of the participants were told that they would be putting with a Nike putter, whereas the other half of participants were not told what putter brand they would be using. Importantly, all participants use the exact same putter, whereas the other half of participants were not told what putter brand they would be using.
重要的是，所有参与者使用的推杆完全相同。有趣的是，我们的结果显示，那些以为自己用的是耐克推杆的人，平均所需的推击次数明显更少，就能把高尔夫球击入洞中。这究竟是怎么回事，阿米拉斯？在某些方面，这与你之前跟我说的穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗装备骑车并感觉自己表现更好的情况有关，但这实际上表明这不仅仅是一种感觉，当你穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的装备时，你可能真的骑得更好。这字面意义上展示了安慰剂效应，也就是他们在这里真正利用的东西，
Importantly, all participants use the exact same putter. And, you know, interestingly, our results showed that those who thought that it was a Nike putter on average needed significantly fewer putts to sink the golf ball. What's going on here, America? In some ways, this is connected to what you were telling me about wearing your land-aham strong gear and biking and feeling like you were doing better, but this actually suggests this isn't just a feeling you actually might have biked better when you are wearing your Landsaham strong gear. What it literally shows is the placebo effect, which is what they are really tapping into
它是真实存在的。“Just do it”的口号你听了那么久。你相信那个品牌赋予了你表现上的优势。以至于对该品牌的心理感知直接转化为你实际表现的能力，让你用更少的杆数完成推击。对我来说，这是最显著、最有力的例子，说明了品牌力量与人们对该品牌叙事或故事中内置的行为活动的感知期望是如此交织在一起，以至于它们真正转化成了本不该因为各种实用目的而存在的品牌优势。我希望当时有人给我戴上各种指标测量仪，并做一个对照实验：在我不知情且双盲的情况下，穿着和不穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的衣服去骑车看看，因为我敢打赌。我记得有几次出门骑车，
here, is real. You have been told about just do it for so long. You believe that that brand endows a performance advantage. So much so that the psychological perceptions of that brand literally translate in your ability to actually perform, to make those puts in fewer strokes. And that to me is the most salient and powerful example of this notion that the power of brand is so intertwined with the perceived expectations of the behavioral activities that are built into that narrative
我记得有一次我想骑上一座山，当时觉得非常吃力。我往下看，能看到手腕上的“坚强直播”手环，我往下看，然后像兰斯那样拉开了骑行服的拉链。这是兰斯准备动真格时常做的一个动作。他会拉开骑行服拉链，把帽子反过来戴。这就意味着他在向竞争对手发出信号：
or that story about the brand that they literally translate into advantages for the brand that really shouldn't be there for all intents and purposes. I wish someone would have put the metrics on me and done the controlled experiment where I didn't know it double-blind or I would be on my bike with and without the land stormstone clothes and see, because I would be willing to bet. I remember days going out and riding the bike.
我接下来要全力以赴了。我要把这一切提升到一个全新的水平。我记得自己当时就是这么做的。我记得自己咬牙冲上了山顶，并在脑海中想象着那些站在山顶为他欢呼的兰斯粉丝，我几乎敢打赌，当我穿着他的装备时，我的表现确实提升了。你过去曾谈到过品牌塑造如何能够成为一股向善的力量，它如何能够帮助那些有使命驱动的公司成就伟大事业。但我很好奇，你是否也能谈谈品牌面临的这一挑战？
I remember this one time where I was trying to go up this one hill and I was struggling. I looked down and I could see my live strong band on my wrist and I looked down and I unzipped my bike jersey like Lance does. This is something Lance used to do when he was about to get serious. He would unzip his jersey and he'd take his cap and he'd flip it around. And he's like, this means that he's signaling to his competitors.
很多人认为它是操纵性的、是不真实的。品牌塑造本身是不是存在一个品牌问题？这太棒了！我喜欢这个问题，尚卡尔。答案是肯定的，这很遗憾，因为品牌塑造本身既非生来善良，也非生来邪恶。我在谈论这个时喜欢用的类比是，品牌塑造和
I'm about to get very, very hard core into this. And I'm about to take it this to a whole new level. I remember doing that. And I remember powering through this hill and getting to the top and imagining in my mind those fans of Lance Lance that would be at the top of the hill cheering him on and I almost unwilling to bet that my performance improved when I was wearing his gear. You've talked in the past about how branding can be a force for good, that it can help companies that are mission-driven companies accomplish great things. But I'm wondering if you can also talk a little bit about this challenge that branding
营销更广义上来说就像一把锤子。你可以拿起一把锤子，如果你愿意的话，你可以为无家可归的人建造一座房子，对吧？但你也可以拿起一把锤子，如果你愿意的话，去砸一个老人的头部并抢走他的钱包。锤子本身并没有什么不好的地方。关键在于你如何使用它，为什么不把它用作变革的力量、用作强大且积极的力量呢？例如，如果你是一家
has. A lot of people see it as manipulative, see it as inauthentic. Does branding have a branding problem? That's fantastic. I love that question, Schumger. The answer is yes, and it's unfortunate because branding in and of itself is neither inherently good or bad. It's the analogy that I like to use when I'm talking about this is that branding and
体育公司的品牌，你能够成为激励消费者想要多锻炼、为了自己和所爱之人的健康而让自己更健康的动力源泉，难道这不棒吗？难道这不是一件好事吗？我认为这是一件好事。（♪ 尾声音乐播放 ♪）阿米拉斯·里德是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学家兼市场营销学教授。阿米拉斯，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。
marketing more generally is like a hammer. And so you can take a hammer and if you want to, you can build a house for a homeless person, right? But you can also take a hammer and if you want to knock an elderly person upside their head and take their wallet. There's nothing inherently bad about a hammer. It's how you use it and why not use it as a force for change as something powerful and positive. For example, if you are
非常感谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能与你交流。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒（Hidden Brain Media）制作。Mid-Roll Media是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的制作团队包括布里杰·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏大脑》的执行编辑。
a brand that is a sports company, isn't it great that you can actually become the motivational impetus for a consumer to want to exercise more and to make themselves healthier for themselves and their loved ones. Isn't that a good thing? I think that's a good thing. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ America's Reed is a psychologist and professor of marketing at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania. America's thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
作为一个体育用品公司品牌，能够真正成为消费者想要多运动、为了自己和所爱之人的健康而努力的动力源泉，这不是很好吗？这难道不是一件好事吗？我认为这是一件好事。[♪ 片尾曲播放中 ♪] 亚美利加·里德是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学和市场营销教授。亚美利加，非常感谢你今天作客《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much, Shunker. It was a pleasure to be with you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Mid-Roll Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Christian Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
非常感谢你，申卡。很高兴能和你在一起。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒公司制作。Mid-Roll Media是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯蒂安·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
Our run song here on this week is Hwana Meryló. Hwana helped to develop the visual identity of our show by designing the Hidden Brain logo. As a journalist, I thought a lot about stories and writing and editing, but hadn't given much thought to visual design. Hwana set me right on that and she helped come up with a visual identity that travels with our show on social media and at live events. Thanks onea, I'm really grateful. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter.
我们本周的片尾曲是《Hwana Meryló》。Hwana通过设计Hidden Brain的标志，帮助我们建立了节目的视觉形象。作为一名记者，我曾花大量时间思考故事、写作和编辑，但对视觉设计却知之甚少。Hwana纠正了我的这一认识，她帮我们构思了一种视觉形象，伴随我们的节目出现在社交媒体和现场活动中。谢谢你，Hwana，我真的非常感激。想了解更多关于Hidden Brain的信息，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。
Again, if you'd like to learn more about my new book, Useful Delusions, go to hiddenbrain.org slash books. I'll post an excerpt on the website. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次提醒，如果你想了解更多关于我的新书《Useful Delusions》的信息，请访问 hiddenbrain.org/books。我会在网站上发布一个书摘。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantum）。我们下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。